mm-hmm
[Music]
hello everyone I am Michael Scott
Dwight has been acting manager for three
months now
a week just feels like three months
Let's see we all have to punch into a
Time Clock which is very old very strong
and has the slot about the size of a
finger
we were all given new business cards big
enough to set us apart from the
competition which is how I learned that
our titles are all now Junior employee
our lunch breaks are staggered to
prevent wasting time
mine's at 10 30 and I find that the
first hour of the day goes by a lot
quicker than the second seven hours stop
stalling
come on
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God
indivisible with liberty
Rivers
excellent morning announcements
there's been a problem with some people
sharing copier codes your copier code is
a distinct 21 digit number that is
unique to you and you only okay don't
share it Joe Bennett our CEO will be
here today for a high level meeting
involving Gabe and myself about what
that's on a need to know basis I thought
I needed to know for your calendar
General meet and greet
so I expect you to be on your best
behavior which means none of you will be
insubordinate nor will you foment
Insurrection question if we've already
fomented Insurrection may we be
grandfathered in
to find fomen you define fomen
where is my desk
that is weird
this is not funny this is totally
unprofessional okay well you're the one
who lost the desk I didn't lose my desk
okay calm down where was the last place
you saw okay who moved my desk I think
you should retrace your steps okay I am
going to tell Michael and this entire
office will be punished
colder
warmer
a little warmer
there you go oh warmer
warmer
warmer warmer warmer cold cold cold back
up
red hot
very hot
foreign
hi Dwight um what sort of discounts are
we giving on the 20 pound
s jim I've given you this information
like 20 times I know
it's by the Rheem
field is now 9.78 science
okay thank you gotta get back to work
wash your hands Kevin
hi my Toby flanderson I'm here to see
George Howard scub this is the prison
uh I am not going in there with
expectations per se
I will meet George Howard scub I will
tell him that I believe he is innocent
I would understand he felt motivated to
hug me
I would understand if a friendship began
how did how did Bogart put it by saying
this is a star to my first friendship
well the good news is no more guilty
conscience at least you know he is the
Strangler
the proof is in the grip
did they say when the vocal cords would
heal
one week
okay
two weeks
okay
you offered your neck in search of the
truth
the proud neck of Justice isn't that the
expression yeah well anyway it was it
was very brave
it really was quite Brave
proceed straight
well we're all for six
Last Chance is the Elmhurst Country Club
other side of the lake on the Southeast
side I'll get it you really don't get it
I thought this would work
through everything I had at that guy
nothing that's how it goes sometimes you
know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait wait no no no it means
Bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no no look it it means
go up to the right Bear right over the
bridge and hook up with 307. make a
right maybe it's a shortcut Dwight it
say go to the right it can't mean that
there's a link he knows where it is
going the machines
remain calm I have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make a U-turn
if possible
[Music]
are you okay
I got you I got it
back up
come on
come on come on
come on
hey Dad
no I know Mom told me
okay
yeah I'll see you then
so what is that
what do you say was it my fault
yeah
he said that you told him how much you
love me
about how you feel when I walk in a room
and about
how you've never doubted for a second
that I'm the woman you want to spend the
rest of your life with
I guess he's never felt that with my mom
even at their best
when you're a kid you assume your
parents are soul mates
my kids are going to be right about that
I guess it also means that sometimes
love affairs look different to the
people inside them
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office
somebody who I think a lot of us cannot
keep
checking out the hottest in the office
award goes to
Ryan the town yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go there you go
what am I gonna do with the award
nothing I I don't know what I'm gonna do
that's the least of my
Pockets right now